so last night uh we watched devonta
smith win the heisman trophy first
receiver since my man desmond howard did
it
it's been a while back in the day it has
been a very long time and one of the
finalists for the heisman trophy
who is going to play in the national
championship game and i saw
i saw what this kid could do firsthand
when he boat-raced my alma mater in the
uh
last week's last year's bowl season not
i usually
talk about that that citrus bowl but mac
jones had an excellent game that day and
what a great season for
the quarterback of the alabama crimson
tide kind enough to call into the
program how are you mac
hey how's it going i am doing fine how
is life for you right now
pretty good pretty good just another day
just another day um
what what has this experience been like
for you this past season mac
walk me through it's been great i'm just
so grateful that we've even had a season
and i can't thank
enough people for for getting that done
and um to play with my teammates
at alabama it's just been a great a
blessing and
we're kind of just looking forward to
finishing finishing this thing off
really strong
yeah and in terms of that uh if you
don't mind me asking um
what what do you know about the game
right now uh or do you
as you and i are talking right now um
are you
uh thinking there's a game on monday
night
between you yeah i mean that's what
we're planning on
i mean everyone's gonna make speculation
but that's kind of been the
motto of the season is people are going
to say things and you know if they have
to change it they have to change it but
we're going to be ready to play monday
night and we're preparing
like we have every other week as if it's
another game but
we're just looking forward to getting a
chance to play
and um how does jaylen waddle look right
now do you think he's going to be in
this mix
regardless i mean he's worked really
hard in his rehab
the past couple months um and you know
he's looking really good but i'd say
you have to call coach david and ask him
i don't know i don't know everything
and you're probably asking the wrong guy
but i mean he does look good and
he's done a great job in his rehab like
i said so we'll see what happens
what uh what do you bring to the table
uh for yourself what do you have within
your
football mind and uh body that you might
not have had week one
mac um i think there's been some good
learning experiences
you know every game presents a different
challenge every defense presents a
different challenge and
identifying the challenge and then uh
kind of dominating that challenge is
something that we've
done so well um i'm just improving from
week to week
fixing the things that you know i did
bad mechanically or
in my reads and then trying to fix it
for the next week and
and move on from week to week and in
terms of just um
the speed of the game uh the the the
pre-snap
part of the game is this you know are
you
are you better at it right now i mean
how have you worked through all that
from week one to yeah this right now i
mean with experience
um you obviously get to see different
looks and then
obviously you have to adjust your
preparation as well so if you didn't do
something well during the week
you have to figure out what you did
wrong and how you can watch film a
little differently
but a lot of it's just preparation like
you said watching film and
taking care of your body and just doing
everything
to the best of your ability so you can
help the team win alabama all-american
quarterback heisman trophy finalist
national championship game quarterback
mack jones here
on the rich eisen show what's the first
time you ever met nick saban when was
the first time
um coach saban uh invited me up to a
camp
and we kind of just sat down and talked
for maybe an hour to an hour and a half
um he kind of just talked the whole time
but i just enjoyed listening to coach
saban
and him talking to my family and his
process and
how he views how he viewed my high
school career and how he thought i was
going to play out as a player
so really just there at the high school
camp
one day in the summer a couple years ago
and so when
you did say that you were gonna go to
alabama when you did have that
opportunity and you took advantage of it
uh tua and hertz were in the fold
correct
at that time yeah right now committed
answer to it yep
okay so um did you have any concerns
about ever
getting some time with alabama when you
first got there
um i knew i wasn't ready to play i was
170 pounds soaking wet
wow i had to make some serious
improvements in the weight room
and the film room on the practice field
so
i kind of just accepted it and figured
eventually i'm going to get a chance
you know with just how many quarterbacks
get a chance to play throughout the
season
you never know when you're going to get
thrown in the game and eventually that
was going to happen and
i couldn't look back when i got the
opportunity and so what did you
glean from tua and hertz watching hertz
go about his business
uh you know with tua there and staying
there
then eventually leaving there and to uh
uh
going down i mean what did you learn
from their adversity
mac yeah i thought they just they always
kept
a level head um good or bad or you know
if they're in their game or not they
always were trying to help each other
out
and i was always kind of the third guy
in the mix you know the middle man but
i was just trying to sit there and learn
as much as i could from those guys
because
you know you don't get that situation
all the time when you're in a great
quarterback room like that
um and things happen from a day-to-day
basis but you just take notes on it and
write it down and say it for later and
learn from it down the road
and what about your future what are you
thinking about on that front
mac walk me through what do you mean
your future after this national
championship game getting ready to go
to the next level obviously um yeah i
don't really know yet i mean
i just really want to focus on this game
that's been a dream of mine so that was
as long as i can remember to play and
start in the national championship game
and uh everything will just take care of
itself i know that sounds cliche but
no that's truly how i'm going to look at
it and i owe my team
and my coaches and all the fans and my
family um my best shot in this game
and hopefully we'll come out with a w
and i i i'd love that your dream
i mean um how long ago did you start
dreaming about this mac
i mean ever since i i picked up a
football really
probably four or five years old i'm just
watching
you know tv and falling in love with the
game and the players that played the
game the right way
so i obviously got a chance to watch the
national championship each year when i
was younger
and um here we are you know a week away
or less than that from
from me getting a chance to play in one
and it just goes back to preparing
really well and treating it like another
game
who was your guy growing up as a kid
that you're like that's the guy i want
to be like
who's that guy um i would just say i
know people probably know this but tebow
um in college just watching him um play
college football with the passion and
the way he did it
i was just down the road so i always got
a chance to watch him at the university
of florida but
um he always did it right but there's
plenty of other people that i
enjoyed watching other teams as well so
are you a jaguars fan
because of where you grew up mac or or
what um i mean not really i guess just
i always watch them obviously uh rooting
for them and hope that they did well
just being from jacksonville and yeah i
went to plenty of games but
um i don't really have a favorite team
anymore i just kind of enjoy watching
you know when you're younger you enjoy
watching the games and now i like
watching them
more from like a technical and
play-calling and offensive
and defensive scheme standpoint so i
just like watching nfl football in
general
okay well that's good and so are you are
you did you grow up a florida state
uh fan because your dad went there
played tennis there right i'm not
mistaken yeah um
a little bit of both honestly and i kind
of just like both florida i mean florida
state
whoever you know whatever team was
playing i kind of enjoyed watching him
but
you know i did like tebow and whenever
they were on definitely watched them and
i mean as time went on got a chance to
watch alabama kind of grow their dynasty
sure
and then in high school got a chance to
you know come up here and
next thing you know i'm here and playing
for coach david and what and what does
it mean to hear
tebow said before the the season he told
the sporting news that uh this was going
to be your season your team
and your season now that i'm hearing
that tebow is your guy i mean that had
to be pretty cool for you mac
gonna be amazing yeah it was really cool
um yeah i think me and tim had a
conversation yesterday
you know just talking about my journey
and how much he inspired me but
at the same time he just said that he
was proud of me and
he knew um that i put a lot of hard work
into it so
i just really happy to get a chance to
just talk with him and
kind of discuss both of our journeys
together was that for
espn was that for the the coverage did
you guys just sat down
or is that the host i think we were just
talking like a little bit yeah
okay that's cool that is great all right
before i let you go i'm going to ask you
to say
i asked this of every alabama crimson
tide player two i asked this of tua
i asked this of tua what's the angriest
you ever made nick saban
i don't know if i can think of a
specific one let's see
i mean yeah the story the hill mary
story i don't know if you've heard that
one
go for it but my freshman year on scout
team
yeah i was supposed to throw a hill mary
like because you're going through
situations
at the end of the game so the defense
has everyone back on the goal line
and this guy our wide receiver derek
keith was a wide receiver and i threw
him a little quick screen
and then i ran i ran behind him and then
he pitched it to me
and i technically scored and spiked the
ball um and then coach saban yelled at
me for like 10 minutes straight
so that was probably the the most i've
ever seen him mad at me but there's been
other times but
i try to just calm down nowadays well
it's just yeah i mean
uh it's interesting tua said the same
thing he tried to calm
nick down at your your coach down after
uh
he he basically told him you know hey
after i took that sack i did win the
national championship with a throw and
he said he kind of got his your co but
but didn't you want to
say at some point like hey you know you
did score right wasn't that the point of
the plays to score
right yeah i mean at that point when i
was scouting i wasn't gonna say
i just kind of walked away and said oh
my gosh that was really embarrassing but
you know i do try and calm pitch david
down during the games and he does a good
job of
keeping me calm so it's a mutual
relationship but i mean it's got to be
amazing right i mean that uh yeah but
you're you're
again i know you're you're in the moment
you're but you
you can't even call him a legend right i
mean he's basically there's belichick
and there's him right now in the
coaching
community and they're they're from the
same tree the fact that you
that you're in his care in his hands and
the staff and you know
that's got it's got a do you ever catch
yourself at any point in time just to
think about that in the moment at all or
not yeah it's it's definitely wild
um i mean he's been doing that for a
while even when i was in high school and
younger
so like i said just getting a chance to
talk to him when i first
met him and then um our relationship
just kind of took off from there but
saban's definitely the greatest college
coach of all time and
i'm just happy to be his quarterback
this year and i want to hopefully bring
back another national championship for
him well mack uh good luck
on that uh first time we got a chance to
talk um
you know uh i sit in a chair at the next
level uh
should you choose that route i look
forward to chatting you in that capacity
as well thanks for the time good luck
sounds good thank you you bet that's uh
that's mack jones
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here